ينضم الان الينا من مستشفى ناصر في
خانيونس المسعف نسيم حسن وهو المسعف في
وحده الاسعاف والطوارئ التابعه لوزاره
الصحه في غزه اهلا بك اذا ما الذي استجد
بالنسبه للظروف التي تعملون بها كمسع
فين نعم نحن في وحده الاسعاف والطوارئ منذ
الامس ليله الامس وا القصف شديد جدا على
محيط مستشفى ناصر ومخيم خان يونس ومدينه
خان يونس ومنطقه حي
الامل هنالك استهدافات كبيره سيارات
الاسعاف لم تتمكن من الوصول الى اماكن
الاستهداف بسبب كثافه القذائف التي تخرج
من المدفعيه الاسرائيليه سيارات الاسعاف
صباح اليوم تمكنت من انتشال العديد من
الشهداء والاصابات اكثر من 30 شهيد وصل
حتى الان مستشفى ناصر وهنالك المئات من
الاصابات ما زال هنالك عشرات الاصابات
والشهداء في شوارع خان يونس هنالك عدم
يعني مقدره سيارات الاسعاف من الوصول الى
منطقه البحر شارع البحر هنالك العديد من
الاصابات ولكن لا يوجد طرق امنه لسيارات
الاسعاف حتى للمواطنين من الوصول الى
منطقه البحر ماذا عن الاتصالات اللاسلكيه
الطريقه التي يتم فيها التواصل بين
الطواقم الطبيه والسيارات
الاسعاف نعم هنالك عجز كبير جدا في وسائل
الاتصال الاتصال شبه مقطوع سيارات الاسعاف
تخرج من مجمع ناصر الطبي نفقد الاتصال بها
بشكل كبير جدا لا نعلم ماذا
يحدث لسيارات الاسعاف ربما سيارات الاسعاف
تتعرض للاستهداف وربما يعني يتم استهدافها
ولا نعلم ما هو مصيرها تخرج سياره الاسعاف
فاقده للاتصال وللتواصل
يعني هنالك صعوبه جدا في وسائل الاتصال
حتى اجهزه المخشير او اللاسلكي شبه مقطوعه
مع سيارات الاسعاف يعني في اليوم الواحد
مثلا منذ ساعات الصباح كم سياره اسعاف
خرجت وك
س طبعا الخف مستمر وواضح ارجو ان تكون في
مكان امن يعني لا نريد ان ان نعرض لخطر
وانت تقف يعني في ساحه
مفتوحه سيد
نسيم هل هل انت في في وضع امن هل تحتاج
للدخول لا يوجد للاسف لا يوجد مكان امن لا
يوجد مكان امن في مدينه خانيونس او مدينه
او احتماء الاستهدافات الان في محيط مجمع
ناصر هنالك قصف مدفعي بالقذائف
الدخانيه في محيط مستشفى ناصر وهنالك
استهدافات برضه من طائرات الاف 16 بالنسبه
لسياره الاسعاف تخرج بصعوبه وتعود بصعوبه
معظم المصابين تاتي على بعض وسائل النقل
مثل مثل الكرات او الحيوانات او التكاتك
او السيارات المدنيه ايه سيارات الاسعاف
غير كافيه لمدينه خانيونس نتحدث عن مدينه
خانيونس بشكل كامل تتعرض للاستهداف من
جميع الطائرات والمدفعيه وحتى الطلقات
الناريه كما تسمعون حتى طائرات الكوت
كابتر تطلق النار بشكل عشوائي على
المواطنين فالسيارات الاسعاف الموجوده
داخل مجمع ناصر حتى في الهلال الاحمر لا
يمكنها التحرك بسبب كثافه النيران وبسبب
مساحه المناطق المستهدفه سيارات الاسعاف
تحاول قدر المستطاع الوصول الى بعض
الاصابات وبعض الشهداء ربما سيارات
الاسعاف تترك الشهداء في الشوارع تصل
اليهم ولكن تتركهم و يعني الاولويه لنا هو
انقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه من المصابين
الاولويه نقل
الاصابات الاولويه هي نقل الاصابات وترك
الشهداء في الميدان حتى يتسنى لنا نقل
اكبر عدد من الاصابات وسياره الاسعاف ربما
تنقل عشرات الاصابات او عشر اصابات ويزيد
في السياره الواحده بسبب كثافه الاصابات
وكثره الاصابات في الشوارع